WAI CHEE DIMOCK: We're
coming to the final
section of The Sound
and the Fury.
And I think a question that
would have to arise for
everyone is why isn't Caddy the
person to be telling the
story in section four?
It seems logical.
Each of her three brothers gets
to tell the story in one
section, so it would seem
logical that Caddy should be
the narrator in section four.
This is not a choice that
Faulkner makes, so we have to
think about why he decides
against using
Caddy as the narrator.
So I can just say that to us,
it might seem as if it would
be good to have a woman's voice
in that last section.
If the missing point of view has
been missing so far, how
it feels to be Caddy, it
certainly would have restored
a more balanced gender
dynamics to The
Sound and the Fury.
So I think that those are the
reasons that one would argue
for having Caddy as
the narrator.
And I would encourage you to
think about that in your
section, to have a discussion
on this point, whether you
would prefer to have Caddy
as a narrator.
But in today's lecture, I'd
like to explore Faulkner's
reasons for deciding against
having Caddy as a narrator and
the choice that he does make,
which is to have not a
first-person singular, not an
"I" telling the story in
section four, but instead to
have omniscient narration told
from an outside point of view.
And I would argue that this
narrative choice on Faulkner's
part is also mapped onto a
thematic emphasis on a
collectivity, on a
communal voice.
So it's not one person's point
of view, but instead really a
group of people, their
interrelations and what
emerges from that
collectivity.
In thinking about these
questions, I think it's useful
to go back a little bit to the
publication history of The
Sound and the Fury.
As you guys know, the first
edition came out in 1929, the
same year as the crash,
as we saw last time.
And in 1946, Random House
decided to bring out The
Portable Faulker, edited by a
very important author and
critic, Malcolm Cowley,
who was also
a big fan of Faulkner.
So Malcolm Cowley was just
editing this Portable
Faulkner, which turned out to be
a very successful edition.
It was used a lot.
And this is the 1946 edition
of The Portable Faulkner.
It really announces the
importance of Faulkner.
He's the kind of author about
whom you would have a portable
something edition.
So it was a great thing
for Faulkner.
And in preparation for The
Portable Faulkner, he decided
to write an appendix to The
Sound and the Fury to be
included in The Portable
Faulkner.
And this is what he said to
Malcolm Cowley before it came
out, October 1945, about
the appendix.
"I should have done this
when I wrote the book.
Then the whole thing would have
fallen into pattern like
a jigsaw puzzle when the
magician's wand touched it."
So that's the degree of
importance that he would
attach to the appendix, although
it seems-- he was
writing in 1945, almost 20 years
after the original The
Sound and the Fury--
he had a somewhat changed
idea about the novel.
His recollection of the novel
seemed a bit skewed, even to
Malcolm Cowley.
So Cowley wrote back to him,
even made Xeroxes of the
original The Sound and the Fury
just to remind him what
was in the original novel and
asked if he would consider
revising the appendix a little
bit in light of what he'd
actually written in The
Sound and the Fury.
But Faulkner wouldn't
have any of that.
He would stick to
his appendix.
And not only that, the same
year, Random House decided to
bring out a dual edition of The
Sound and the Fury and As
I Lay Dying.
We'll be reading As I Lay Dying
a little bit later on.
In 1946, those two were brought
out in a single dual
edition under the Modern Library
imprint, which is a
cheaper paperback edition
of Random House Books.
So it came out in the Modern
Library edition.
And in preparation for that,
Faulkner was also very
emphatic that the appendix
should be in there.
So this is what he wrote to
Robert Linscott, senior editor
at Random House, the
beginning of 1946.
"When you read it, the appendix,
you will see how it
is the key to the whole book.
And after reading it, the four
sections as they stand now
fall into clarity and place.
When you issue the book, print
this appendix first and title
it, 'Appendix.' Then
continue with the
sections as they now are.
Be sure and print the
appendix first."
So Faulkner really has very
strange ideas about the
importance of the appendix that
seem a little dubious
even to his devoted fan,
Malcolm Cowley.
And the appendix was in fact
included in the 1946 Modern
Library edition.
And it was included in many
editions of The Sound and the
Fury all through the
'50s, '60s, '70s.
In the '80s, editors started
taking it out.
And so in our edition, as you
can see, there's no appendix
in our edition, the Vintage
edition, which is also
published by Random House.
But just for your reference, I
will post the appendix onto
our website so you will see for
yourself whether Faulkner
has a point, whether it is,
in fact, the key to The
Sound and the Fury.
But once again, remember that
lots of people actually had
reservations about the appendix,
so don't think that
it is, in fact, the
key to the novel.
But the appendix does tell us
quite a bit about how Faulkner
thinks about Caddy and
how he thinks about
the rest of the novel.
So this is his very, very
long entry on Caddy.
"Candace, Caddy.
Doomed and knew it.
Accepted the doom without either
seeking or fleeing it.
Loved her brother despite him.
Loved him not only in spite of
but because of the fact that
he must value above all not her
but the virginity of which
she was custodian and on which
she placed no value whatever.
Knew the brother loved
death best of
all and was not jealous.
Vanished in Paris with the
German occupation, 1940."
For a good part of that entry
on Caddy, it is a very, very
good summary of her place in
The Sound and the Fury.
And you can see why Faulkner
would not want her to tell the
story on her own, that her
importance in the novel is her
importance to her brothers, and
the way in which she is
really not important.
She's an ideal of virginity.
She's the repository of
virginity that is so important
both to Benjy and to Quentin.
And so she's really a cipher
for her brothers.
And that's why she is what she
is, always existing in the
minds of her brothers, but never
having an independent
existence of her own.
But there's one other weird
thing that comes out of the
appendix, which comes out
in this little detail.
And Faulkner would go on
to elaborate on that.
Faulkner creates a whole other
story about Caddy, that she
went to Paris, that she was
there, apparently, when the
Germans occupied Paris.
And then there was this other
detail about a picture of her
falling into the hands of a
librarian in Jefferson, a
woman who looked like Caddy
who was hanging out with a
German Nazi officer.
And the librarian wasn't sure
that that was Caddy, but she
showed the picture to Jason,
she showed the picture to
Dilsey, and nobody knew whether
or not that woman who
was hanging out with
a Nazi officer,
whether that was Caddy.
So a whole new mystery unfolds
in the course of the appendix,
and clearly Faulkner maybe was
even thinking of another novel
based on Caddy.
It's his way of writing a
new novel back into--
you can see that she would not
be the appropriate person to
be telling the story
in section four.
So we'll see what Faulkner
actually ends up with, what he
chooses as his representative
in section four, the most
authoritative way of telling the
story, which is actually
through a third party, through
this omniscient narration.
And that is linked to some
degree with his understanding
of what section four is about.
And that is the two people that
he mentions at the end of
the appendix.
"And that was all.
The others were not Compsons.
They were black.
Luster.
A man, aged 14, who was not only
capable of the complete
care and security of an idiot
twice his age and three times
his size, but could keep
him entertained.
Dilsey.
They endured."
So these are the two people
that he would like to talk
about, and those are the centers
in section four.
And I actually agree with
Faulkner that that
makes a lot of sense.
They have been so important
all through the novel, and
finally section four is devoted
to Luster and Dilsey
and the world that revolves
around them and the future
that emerges from this focus
on Luster and Dilsey.
We already have seen something
about Luster, that he is very
young, but he's capable of
replacing Caddy in taking good
care of Benjy.
What is odd about these three
words used to describe Dilsey
is "Dilsey.
They endured." So Faulkner is
super-conscious of pronouns,
and he has a very odd use
of what appears to be a
non-matching pronoun.
It should have been "Dilsey.
She endures." And so
he introduces the
third-person plural.
And I would argue that section
four is in fact a section
dominated by that pronoun that
is invoked in this very
peculiar fashion.
It is the section devoted to the
third-person plural by way
of someone like Dilsey.
So in the rest of the lecture,
I'll be thinking about section
four along those lines.
This is the first thing
that we notice,
this omniscient narration.
And these are the other points
that I would like to make
about Dilsey.
Through her, we see the
legacy of slavery.
We see a shift between
outside and inside.
Omniscient narration is an
external point of view, but
quite often, there's a shift
back to the interior of
Dilsey, and along with that
shift, a tension between sight
and sound, between the visual
and the auditory registers.
Because it's a question of
endurance. "They endure."
Faulkner is thinking about the
future of race and of the
United States by way of race,
the tomorrow of race.
And we'll test a concept that
we used last time, that we
took from Raymond Williams,
the knowable community.
We'll ask whether or not that
could be resurrected in
section four.
And the question of resurrection
comes up because
section four is Easter Sunday,
is the day on which some
resurrection takes place.
So Faulkner is using that as
the frame for the idea of
resurrecting something else.
And obviously, we think because
Benjy is in there
still, everyone else--
Jason is still there--
there's a possibility of a
cross-racial "we" emerging
from "They endured."
And as promised last time, the
horse, Queenie, actually makes
an appearance as well in
section four of The
Sound and the Fury.
In fact, she's very,
very important.
So we're not quite at a place
where we can talk about a
community made up of humans
and non-humans, but it is
interesting that it is not the
automobile but the horse that
comes back in a big way
at the very end of The
Sound and the Fury.
So let's start out with
omniscient narration.
And I think that there's a
temptation on our part to
think that omniscient narration
is going to be
benign, that, OK, section one
is told by Benjy, who's
mentally retarded.
Section two is told
by Quentin, who is
going to kill himself.
Section three is told by Jason,
totally obnoxious, but
very sad, very pathetic
character.
Section four is told by an
omniscient narrator, so we
might assume that this is going
to be benign, that this
is going to be full
of goodwill.
That is not necessarily
the case.
And in fact, the omniscient
narration actually begins with
a fairly off-putting, external,
and objectifying
view of Dilsey, in the sense
that she's turned into an
inert object to be observed.
So it's a very striking and to
some extent puzzling narrative
choice on Faulkner's part.
This is the morning
of Easter Sunday.
"Dilsey opened the door of the
cabin and emerged, needled
laterally into her flesh,
precipitating not so much a
moisture as a substance
partaking of the quality of
thin, not quite congealed oil.
She wore a stiff velvet cape
with a border of mangy and
anonymous fur about a dress of
purple silk, and she stood in
the door for a while with her
myriad and sunken face lifted
to the weather, and one gaunt
hand flac-soled as the belly
of a fish."
That's a repulsive picture
of Dilsey.
And it is first of all observing
her at very, very
close range.
This is really Dilsey captured
on not even a micro-register,
but almost like a nano-register,
in the sense
that we're not even seeing her
eyes, we're not seeing her
hair or the possible smile
or non-smile on her face.
We're looking at something that
maybe is sweat coming out
of her, but it is
not moisture.
It is a thin layer of congealed
oil that's sticking
to her skin.
A completely physical,
mechanical description of
Dilsey at very close range.
It's almost Faulkner telling
us that when it comes to
omniscient narration, he's
as good as the next guy.
He can give us the most minute
details, the most minute
impersonal and non-benign
level of
detail attached to Dilsey.
From that very minute and
non-benign-- in the sense that
it's impersonal , it's
completely neutral--
description of Dilsey, we move
on to a slightly larger scale.
And now we notice the clothes
that she's wearing.
And she's wearing
fancy clothes.
She's wearing clothes too
good for her station.
She's wearing a velvet cape
and a silk dress.
So we know that those are
not really her clothes.
Those are the hand-me-downs
discarded by her mistress,
Mrs. Compson, and she's
wearing them.
So right there, we have the
legacy of slavery encoded into
the articles of clothing that
are to be found on Dilsey.
And I would emphasize that
they are to be found on
Dilsey, in the sense that
there's not a whole lot of
agency in Dilsey choosing
to wear those clothes.
They are just hand-me-downs
given to her.
So slavery is also something
that was historically a given
and quite possibly is
still a given in
the twentieth century.
The African-American characters
in section four are
not slaves anymore.
This is the twentieth century,
slavery was a thing in the
past. But there is still the
legacy of slavery, the shadow
of slavery, hanging over
everyone's heads as Dilsey is
still wearing the old clothes
of her mistress.
So in that sense, in thinking
about the legacy of slavery,
The Sound and the Fury could
be seen in the company of
other narratives--
not novels, but narratives--
that were emerging or being
produced in the 1930s, just a
little later.
And this was the project
sponsored by the Federal
Writers' Projects during the
Great Depression, when lots of
unemployed authors were going
around the country under the
sponsorship of the federal
government to talk to
ex-slaves and to get the life
stories and to make sure that
those are on record
and archived.
So there's that desire in the
'30s to capture something that
would otherwise vanish
forever.
And those are really
interesting
archives to look at.
If you ever decide to go to
graduate school in literature
and decide to do something on
Faulkner, it would be very
interesting to look at those
in conjunction with what
Faulkner says about the slaves
in The Sound and the Fury.
But that's just a reference
point that--
what else is happening.
Within The Sound and the Fury,
we see that the legacy of
slavery is basically a
hostility, a visual hostility,
directed against Dilsey.
She's an enormously, enormously
sympathetic
character, but she's not
completely immune from the
hostile gaze that is part of
the omniscient narration.
Omniscient narration is
completely neutral.
It doesn't side with anyone.
It can be both for someone
or against someone.
And initially used by Faulkner,
it actually is used
against Dilsey.
But as is the custom with
Faulkner, quite often, we see
that he is giving us both
sides to the picture.
That neutral, maybe even hostile
view of Dilsey is
quickly modified.
And it's modified when sound
enters the picture.
So we're getting pretty much the
same dynamics that we've
seen in Fitzgerald.
The interplay of sight and
sound, the auditory and the
visual registers, almost always
produces a change in
the visual field.
And this is what happens
to Dilsey.
And it happens in
one significant
setting, the kitchen.
Dilsey is preparing breakfast.
"Dilsey prepared to
make biscuit.
As she ground the sifter
steadily above the bread
board, she sang, to herself at
first, something without
particular tune or words,
repetitive, mournful and
plaintive, austere, as she
ground a faint, steady snowing
of flour onto the bread board.
The stove had begun to heat the
room and to fill it with
murmurous minors of the fire,
and presently she was singing
louder, as if her voice too
had been thawed out by the
growing warmth."
So as voice takes over,
the pronoun also
changes a little bit.
We're still sticking with a
third-person singular pronoun,
but already there's a degree
of interiority emerging in
this portrait.
It is not just an external
view of Dilsey, but the
quality of sound that is
coming out of her.
And as the quality of sound is
coming out of her, we see what
she's like when she's working,
when she's in a place that
she's familiar with, that
she's at home in.
That really is her domain.
The kitchen is her domain.
And when Dilsey is in her
domain, she turns into a
different kind of person.
The sound that she makes is
still attached to the work
that she has to do.
So there's no cessation of work
as she sings, but the
very rhythm of work enables
Dilsey to turn into a
different kind of character.
She's very, very different when
she's singing than when
she's seen as an inert object
outside her cabin.
And one thing that happens, one
other thing that emerges
about Dilsey in the kitchen
is that she has
a relation to time.
And here, I just want to say
that in section four, there's
actually both something that
emerges about Dilsey but that
is also a backward reference to
a very emblematic moment in
each of the three preceding
sections.
So what we'll see in section
four, I think this is the
structure that Faulkner is
working, a really very
intricate and very well-crafted
structure, is to
give us one moment that is
emblematic of Dilsey that is a
response, a rejoinder, or an
amendment to an earlier moment
that was problematic in one
of the preceding sections.
So let's look at this very
interesting moment, very
memorable and graphic moment,
although with sounds thrown in
about Dilsey, also
in the kitchen.
"...On the wall above a
cupboard, invisible save at
night by lamp light and even
then evincing an enigmatic
profundity because it had but
one hand, a cabinet clock
ticked, then with a preliminary
sound as if it had
cleared its throat,
struck five times.
'Eight o'clock,' Dilsey said."
So the clock is striking
five o'clock.
Dilsey knows it's
eight o'clock.
She's not up at five.
Even though she's hard-working,
she's
not up at five AM.
She's up at eight AM.
She knows that this
is eight o'clock.
She knows the clock very well.
So we are back to the notion
of a knowable community.
And in this case, it is
a community between
Dilsey and the clock.
And significantly, it emerges
in the course of
working, hard labor--
well, hard enough--
but it's in the course
of working.
And it's in a very
familiar setting.
This is the most important
thing, that the kitchen is a
familiar setting to
Dilsey, and the
clock is also her familiar.
It is a mechanical contrivance,
but in this case,
it is a mechanical contrivance
that isn't quite working.
First of all, the clock
is really not
doing a number of things.
It is invisible in
broad daylight.
You can only see it at night by
lamp light, and even then,
you can barely see it, because
it only has one hand.
So it's not functioning
properly.
It's also not functioning
properly because it's not
telling the right time.
But all that only makes the
kitchen a more important
knowable community.
It's only when you have a
defective instrument and you
know that instrument very well
that you can prove that you
actually know this
domain very well.
So Dilsey's knowledge of this
place is proven without--
it's beyond doubt that she knows
this place very well.
And this emblematic moment about
Dilsey obviously brings
back an equally emblematic
moment about Quentin and his
relation to his watch.
This is the first thing that
we know about Quentin.
So let's look at this opening
of his section and his
relation to time, as we have
seen, and especially his
relation to his own watch,
his grandfather's watch.
"When the shadow of the sash
appeared on the curtains, it
was between seven and eight
o'clock and then
I was in time again...
I went to the dresser and took
up the watch with the face
still down.
I tapped the crystal on the
corner of the dresser and
caught the fragments of glass in
my hand and put them in the
ashtray and twisted the hands
off and put them in the tray.
The watch ticked on."
So two points of context between
the Dilsey section and
this section.
Eight o'clock, same time,
except that they have a
completely different relation to
eight o'clock, to the time
that is eight o'clock.
For Dilsey, it's another day.
And we know that there'll
be many more eight
o'clocks for her.
For Quentin, this is the last
eight o'clock he would ever
experience.
It is the very end of
the line for him.
So right then and there, that
tells us fully who has a
future and who doesn't.
But the other thing is that
Dilsey is able to make do with
a broken clock.
Quentin is the one who has a
well-functioning watch that he
smashes, twists off the
hands of that watch.
And of course, he hurts his hand
in the course of smashing
that watch.
So right there, it is a capsule
summary of his futile
battle with time and the
way Quentin gets
bloodied on this day.
This is finally the day when
he loses some kind of
virginity, loses the virginity
about time, maybe.
He is bloodied in his
struggle with time.
So it's a very eloquent
rejoinder to that earlier
moment, but also a rewriting
of that earlier moment.
It is a dead end for Quentin.
There's no doubt about it.
There's no way Faulkner can keep
on-- although, I should
say, actually, in terms of
Faulkner's own novels, he
actually wrote another novel,
Absalom, Absalom!,
resurrecting Quentin
in that novel.
So he actually manages to find a
way to bring Quentin back as
well by writing another
novel about him.
But within The Sound and the
Fury, there's no way he can
bring Quentin back alive.
And instead the only way he can
resurrect Quentin in some
fashion is to resurrect him by
way of Dilsey and her ability
to make do with time, to come to
terms with time, to come to
terms both with a defective
present, and in coming to
terms with a defective
present, to
live on to the future.
So by way of Dilsey, we can
start thinking about the
all-important concept
of tomorrow.
And it has to do with the
tomorrow of race.
So we know, first of all, the
importance of the kitchen and
what takes place
in the kitchen.
We also know in the rest of
the section that there's
another place that is as
important as the kitchen, and
that is the black church.
So these are the two emblematic
locales where there
could be a tomorrow and where
there could be an interesting
development to that pronoun,
third-person plural.
And we'll see that
in the church.
the central figure in that
church is the preacher, the
Reverend Shegog, and we'll
see what he does.
And we know that this is Easter
Sunday, so this is the
resurrection of something.
And we'll finally talk about
the possibility of that
utopian ideal, a cross-racial
"we."
But first of all, this is the
church, the Christian
Methodist Episcopal church
in Oxford, Mississippi.
It's a historic church.
And I want to bring to your
attention a figure who's
written eloquently about the
black church, and that is
someone you might have
read in another
class, W. E. B. Du Bois.
He was a very important author,
but he also actually
studied sociology.
So he wrote a 1903 book called
The Negro Church, basically a
sociological report based on
lots of field work about black
churches in the South.
Most of us probably haven't
read The Negro Church--
probably only specialists would
be reading that book--
but there's another book by Du
Bois that I bet a lot you have
read or heard of, The Souls
of Black Folk, also
coming out in 1903.
And because he was doing this
sociological field work at the
same time as he was writing this
book, not surprisingly,
he had a lot to say about
the black church.
He has a whole chapter called
"The Faith of Our Fathers" in
which he talks at length
about the black church.
And this is what he says.
And he links the black church
back to the religion of the
slaves, so this is another way
in which there's the legacy of
slavery in the centrality
of the black church.
"Three things characterized the
religion of the slave--
the Preacher, the Music,
and the Frenzy.
The preacher is the most unique
personality developed
by the Negro on the
American soil.
A leader, a politician, an
orator, a boss, an intriguer,
an idealist--
all these he is and ever too the
center of a group of men
now twenty, now a thousand
in number."
Du Bois' account of the
preacher is really
interesting.
Because this preacher is both
someone who is a conveyor of a
form of Christianity, a form of
spirituality, but Du Bois
also sees that he's
more than that.
He's a politician.
He's an orator.
He has to be very good
at what he's doing.
He's a boss to some extent.
So there are all these other
non-spiritual dimensions
attached to the preacher.
And that is indeed the case,
because the black church, even
though a church like this seems
very local, because it's
part of the Methodist church.
The local Methodist church
actually belongs to a national
denomination.
The Methodist church is a
national denomination.
And quite often, preachers would
actually go from one
city to another.
The preacher is not always
stationed at one place.
And that turns out to be the
case with the Reverend Shegog
in The Sound and the Fury.
This is the background to why
this preacher is actually
brought all the way
from St. Louis.
He's not the local preacher.
He's brought in for the
Easter Sunday service
especially from St. Louis.
And so there's something both
very special but potentially
alien about him.
And Faulkner gives us once again
a two-part portrait of
the Reverend Shegog, a two-part
portrait that is
based on a reversal.
As with Dilsey, we see an
external view of the Reverend
Shegog, and then we see a much
more interior view of the
Reverend Shegog.
But this is the external view,
looking at him strictly from
the standpoint of a small-town
black church, looking at this
supposedly very important
visitor coming from St. Louis.
"The visitor was undersized,
in a shabby alpaca coat.
He had a wizened black face like
a small, aged monkey...
When the visitor rose to speak
he sounded like a white man.
His voice was level and cold.
It sounded too big to have
come from him and they
listened at first through
curiosity, as they would have
to a monkey talking.
They began to watch him as they
would a man on a tight
rope."
So this is very much an external
view of the Reverend
Shegog, and it's not
a sympathetic view.
He's someone that the
congregation for the black
local church was highly
suspicious of.
And in fact, they were very
disappointed in him, that he
had come all the way from St.
Louis-- he's been brought in
at some expense from
St. Louis--
and it turns out that
he's much, much less
impressive-looking than their
own preacher whom they would
see every week.
So it was a terrible
disappointment for them to
look at this monkey-like,
tiny, clownish figure.
And even when he starts
speaking, he's still
off-putting.
They're not warming up to him
right away, because he sounds
like a white man.
This is a very peculiar detail
on Faulkner's part, and
there's no other way of
accounting for it other than
that he was really thinking of
the preacher as Du Bois would,
that he's not just a
representative of some kind of
spirituality, but that he's
also an operator and a
politician.
And speaking like a black man
is possibly a sign that he
operates in that mode.
But we get a reversal.
We get a switch to a totally
different view of
the Reverend Shegog.
And I should say that this
external view of the Reverend
Shegog really has to do with
looking at him as an inert
object, this impersonal,
objective
gaze directed at him.
And he indeed looks like a
monkey if you just look at him
as a single individual.
So from that alienating
perspective, we now turn to
another look at him, which is
not as a single individual,
but as a communal voice.
So this is the two poles that
Faulkner tries to negotiate by
way of the Reverend Shegog,
that he could be looked at
just as a single individual,
this big-shot preacher from
St. Louis, or he could be fused
with a community as a
voice speaking for them.
And he takes on a completely
different set of qualities
when he's seen in that light,
fused with the community.
"And the congregation seemed
to watch with its own eyes
while the voice consumed him,
until he was nothing and they
were nothing and there was not
even a voice but instead their
hearts were speaking to one
another in chanting measures
beyond the need for words, so
that when he came to rest
against the reading desk, his
monkey face lifted and his
whole attitude, that of a
serene, tortured crucifix that
transcended its shabbiness and
insignificance and made it of
no moment, a long moaning
expulsion of breath rose from
them, and a woman's
single soprano--
'Yes, Jesus!'"
We're beginning to figure out
why the external, objectifying
view of the black characters is
so deliberately demeaning,
is so deliberately
hostile to them.
Because Faulkner in fact wants
to suggest that most people,
if you just look at them,
they're really nothing to
write home about.
They are very sad-looking
specimens of humanity.
But the most important thing
is that these sad-looking
specimens of humanity can be
transformed under the proper
circumstances.
And listening to the voice--
in this case, listening to the
voice of the Reverend Shegog--
in conjunction with the voice
of the black congregation,
that is one circumstance when
we completely forget the
insignificant physical
appearance of this man.
He becomes nothing, the
congregation becomes nothing,
and that's a good thing.
When they become nothing, then
what really does register is
that voice and what that voice
is able to do for the
congregation.
So this is without question the
moment of epiphany in The
Sound and the Fury, and it's
by way of this initially
dubious-looking preacher, who
then actually transcends that
and is able, in fact, to do what
is supposed to be done on
Easter Sunday, which is to
bring about some kind of
resurrection.
So this is what we're already
beginning to see happen.
We've already seen a little bit
of it in Dilsey's relation
to the clock in her kitchen, and
now we see something else
that also happens
in the kitchen.
And it is the other black
character, Luster, and Benjy
in the kitchen.
Section four, Benjy comes
back in a big way.
So in many ways, this is Benjy
almost incorporated into the
black community.
We've mentioned earlier that the
way in which he and Luster
constitute a unit, and Luster
being his significant other.
And here, we once again see
Benjy as Luster's significant
other and the other way
around as well.
"Luster fed him with skill
and detachment.
Now and then, his attention
would return long enough to
enable him to feint the spoon
and cause Ben to close his
mouth upon the empty air, but it
was apparent that Luster's
mind was elsewhere.
His other hand lay on the back
of the chair and upon that
dead surface, it moved
tentatively, delicately, as if
he were picking an inaudible
tune out of the dead void.
And once he even forgot to tease
Ben with the spoon while
his fingers teased out of the
slain wood a soundless and
involved arpeggio until Ben
recalled him by whimpering
again."
Very odd detail about Luster.
Luster doesn't play any musical
instrument at all.
Faulkner is counter-factually
representing him as picking an
inaudible tune.
And not only is it an inaudible
tune, not only has
Luster become a musician in this
moment, but he's playing
a special kind of music,
an arpeggio.
So what is an arpeggio?
It is a special musical
technique, the chord not being
played in unison, but
played in sequence.
Usually, the chord would be
played together, but the
arpeggio is one in which you
play the chord in sequence,
one at a time.
So the English translation for
the Italian word "arpeggio" is
actually a broken chord.
And this is actually a kind of
music that Luster plays is
that slavery and the legacy of
slavery, is that broken chord.
It is not the most harmonious
kind of music.
But as we know, Schubert
actually has a great piece of
music called the Arpeggione
Sonata.
It's a wonderful piece of music,
and it's one of the
most famous signature
pieces by Schubert.
But Luster isn't quite
playing that.
But his arpeggio is interesting
in that Faulkner's
turning this not very well
schooled black character into
a trained musician.
So this is the reconstitution of
a knowable community based
on a special kind
of knowledge.
And we know that Luster actually
does know something.
He knows something.
That's why he's absent-minded.
His mind is fixated on something
else, something that
only he knows.
So let's go back to what it is
that Luster knows that makes
him so absent-minded
at this moment.
This is the second reference
back to an earlier moment in
an earlier section.
This is actually the very ending
of the Benjy section.
So that one is resurrected
as well in the
absent-mindedness of Luster.
Same configuration,
Luster and Benjy.
"He put my gown on.
I hushed, and then Luster
stopped, his
head toward the window.
Then he went to the window
and looked out.
He came back and took my arm.
Here she come, he said.
Be quiet now.
We went to the window
and looked out.
It came out of Quentin's
window and climbed
across into the tree.
We watched the tree shaking.
The shaking went
down the tree.
Then it came out, and
we watched it
go across the grass.
Then we couldn't see it."
Benjy is totally clueless
at this moment.
Luster is already knowledgeable
about what
exactly is coming out of
Quentin's window, so that when
we do find out in section four
that Quentin has run away,
that she's taken all of Jason's
money with her when
she runs away, that is
old news to Luster.
He's known all through
the novel, starting
from section one.
That bit of knowledge is
in his possession.
So this is the reconstitution
of a knowable community for
Luster is that he is familiar.
Quentin is his familiar.
He knows her well enough to know
that this is something
that she might do.
And it is that reconstitution
of a knowable community that
once again resurrects this
previous moment from Benjy and
allows it to take
on a new life.
So since we're already looking
at the structure of two
resurrected earlier moments in
section four of The Sound and
the Fury, let's look
at the resurrection
of one other thing.
And not surprisingly, it is the
third brother who would
get resurrected in
that moment.
And this has to do with a
landmark in Oxford, which is
the Courthouse Square.
And we know that Luster and
Benjy are in a habit of going
out for a ride with Queenie,
the horse.
But in this case, at the very
end of The Sound and the Fury,
something seems to
be going wrong.
Luster and Benjy go on a ride
probably every day, and
nothing especially happens.
It's just a peaceful ride.
But on this one occasion,
something
seems to be going wrong.
And Benjy is bellowing without
stopping on this ride.
Something seems to
be going wrong.
Luster, for all his knowledge
of what Quentin does, is
actually incapable of
controlling this situation.
He's unable to stop Benjy
from bellowing.
It actually takes Jason's
intervention to stop the
bellowing of Benjy.
So let's look at what it is
that Jason is able to do.
"With a backhanded blow, he
hurled Luster aside and caught
the reins and sawed Queenie
about and doubled the reins
back and slashed her
across the hips.
He cut her again and again into
a plunging gallop, while
Ben's hoarse agony roared about
them, and swung her
about to the right
of the monument.
Then he struck Luster over the
head with his fist. 'Don't you
know better than to take him
to the left?' he said.
He reached back and struck
Ben, breaking the
flower stalk again.
"...Queenie moved again.
Her feet began to clop-clop
steadily again, and at once,
Ben hushed.
Luster looked quickly back
over his shoulder,
then he drove on.
The broken flower drooped over
Ben's fist, and his eyes were
empty and blue and serene again,
as cornice and facade
flowed smoothly once more from
left to right, post and tree,
window and doorway and
signboard, each in its ordered
place."
So that was what went wrong
initially with the ride is
that Luster, for some reason,
had forgotten that they're
supposed to go to the right
of the monument.
He makes Queenie go to the left,
and so everything is
happening in the wrong order.
And because Benjy cannot stand
anything happening in the
wrong order, nothing will
stop him from bellowing.
So this is a very interesting
moment when Faulkner has
granted to Luster a
lot of knowledge.
He knows Quentin very well,
but for some reason, he
doesn't know Benjy on
this one occasion.
It takes Jason actually to
demonstrate his knowledge of
his own brother, Benjy.
He doesn't love Benjy, but
he knows Benjy very well.
He knows that it would have
to be to the right of the
monument, and he's able to
correct that mistake.
So after all we've seen, Jason's
terrible problems with
the automobile, at the very end
of The Sound and the Fury,
Faulkner is able to resurrect
Jason into a
much happier fate.
Automobile is gone.
It's back to the world of
horses and carriages, a
19th-century world still
lingering on and to some
extent accommodating Jason
even in the 20th century.
It's not a pretty sight.
It's not a non-violent world.
Jason is still hitting Luster.
He's breaking Ben's flower.
So none of the obnoxious
things about
Jason have gone away.
He hasn't turned into
a sweet person.
He's still a monster.
But while he remains a monster,
Faulkner has made his
world one that he can live in
and that he can be a hero of
sorts in this very
one brief moment.
He can be the person who comes
to the rescue and set
everything back onto the
right track, literally.
So this is a way in which the
very ending of The Sound and
the Fury is in fact an Easter
Sunday story
about resurrection.